[Applaudissements]
gt rien c'est rien c'est rien ne vous
retournez pas
a turckheim
on va tout de suite joué à la bullshit
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on va régler les chaînes box
allusivement plaçant oui obama la web
alors il a fait venir avec tes pattes
serpent pas la secte de bois de
charpente vous inquiétez pas allez bonne
année mathieu aller vers ses bonnes
années
allez on y va je vais poser des
questions à shy'm bizimana la hd et les
attentions
attention donc matthieu delormeau je
vais vous poser des questions sur shine
d'accord dès que vous commettez une
erreur shy'm choisira une boxe ici c'est
l'achat in box d'accord pour choisir les
bonbons du coup alors je vous le dis il
ya des crocodiles l1 et crocodiles les
bons mots et bonbons et les crocodiles
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais ça ça c'est la boîte coule
d'accord c'est la boîte coule je
regarderai avance qu'il ya d'accord pas
de serpents certes on a six merde qua
non à iad est certes on n'en sait rien
des serpents d'ici un petit noon ou
nounou
non mais ça c'est des petits serpents
c'est comme des bonbons des bonbons mais
ça c'est rien ça se court dans le slip
c'est rien c'est parti attention
questions sur shine si vous vous trompez
choisira une shy'm box c'est lui qui
répond matthieu delormeau matthieu
delormeau et souper et c'est pas bientôt
fini
voilà qui voudraient téléphoner
[Applaudissements]
je ne compte faire soit assez matthieu
boone de dollars
attention que signifie l'onem des eaux
et il me regarde là ici dans les yeux
c'est facile que signifie le m2 shy'm à
malices b malgache
c'est martin houde et matthieu delormeau
martinique n'est pas tricher non juin
sous le nom je prends pas juré le
connais jean reno sur la tête du
pakistan mais quel beau pays je n'ai pas
triché
c'est pas toujours à demander un truc
après oh je vous entends pas et je vous
emmerde
oui c'est bien c'est bien martinique
bien joué
[Musique]
allez tous que ce que child a bien sûr
de martinique voilà sinon bon et au mais
qu'est-ce qui peut activer ce qui
l'attend mais combien mais on a fait six
voulait partir et ce que ça allait
partir
est-ce qu'on m'aiderait à oui c'est un
détail mais comme j'avais dit que je
tenais c'est shy'm il ya des gens sur
twitter qui me croyais pas et qui m'ont
un peu j'aurais tu te la pètes donc je
voulais juste savoir si ça elle pouvait
dire
voilà j'ai ça en moi car je vous la
foule dans la donne et retournez vous
attendez vous à vous êtes beaucoup plus
beau comme ça en plus de la confiance
d'asie je vous fais confiance à hérode
retourner vous complétez ces paroles de
la chanson est alors de shy'm et alors
mais qu'est ce que ça te fait si j'ose
les copier coller les décolletés les
cravates ou les ne pas aller 3 secondes
maintenant les décolletés les décolletés
attention vérification solar
et allah alors jeanne duval et choisir
une boîte et c'est moi qui vais m'en
[ __ ] non la clochette anuga 7 6 non
vous êtes sur un 3g regarde c'est quoi
c'est quoi c'est rien ou mathieu sait
rien n'a pas d'amis je perds l'ami de
shy'm je vais la montre à la caméra est
cool regarde pas le match le retour je
regardais pas si on peut les couper au
couteau couper le retour est cool je
vais la montrer aux téléspectateurs
robin shine
ouais c'est vous qui avez choisi la
boîte c'est vous qui allez lui verser
oui anna connais vous allez monter par
la non c'est rien c'est rien à manger la
grosse à les y attend je n'ai pas trop
attendre d'autre qu'à lui dire
russell
respectives est amazigh adoptive est
banni
c'est le syndrome les vallées
à
[Applaudissements]
therrien c'est rien c'est rien ne me
retournais pas regarde pas
non
tout va bien
ça m'énerve du bourg je passe maintenant
sortez [ __ ] t'es vraiment ce que j'y
vais leur parler
s'il vous plaît les chalets serpent ckac
a beaucoup souffert dans sa liste un
ancien d'énergie du monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
en sortant est ruinée démarrant view
bayellois si je passe la tête et qui me
comment charmer nos bras s'il n'est pas
derrière vient le chercher
non mais pas les prendre par la non pas
quoi attendre qu'elles sont devant nous
[Applaudissements]
oui
[Musique]